okay so luke skywalker showing up at the
end of season two of the mandalorian was
completely mind-blowing for me it's the
best scene in a star wars property since
the original trilogy and there's a
number of reasons why it works so well
up until this point disney's handling of
star wars had been mixed to say the
least and the last jedi has had more
back and forth over it than whether hand
shot first or not the sequel trilogy was
a bit more clunky and the constant
changing of direction left a lot of the
most beloved characters feeling that
they didn't get the send-off that they
deserved luke skywalker was definitely
one of these and to see him tossing
lightsabers away drinking blue milk and
looking like nick nolte made many fans
feel like our last memories of the hero
wouldn't be pleasant ones now i actually
did quite enjoy the force projection
that we saw in the finale of the last
jedi but even then i did feel a bit
short-changed as it's not really him
going out in a blaze of glory like
obi-wan and anakin the rise of skywalker
did bring him back through the use of
force ghosts but for many it seemed like
the last memory of luke would be him
going out on his back as a shell of his
former self that is until the
mandalorian came along and brought the
character back in a big way that felt
like not only redemption for him but
also the franchise itself now up top
i'll say that i absolutely love both
seasons of the show i think the first
one did a really good job of recapturing
the feel of the star wars universe and
it did so without relying too heavily on
fan service we thought that we were
getting a holy original story and thus
when season 2 came along it made the
inclusion of the expanded lore
characters seem even more overwhelming
there was of course kobanth boba fett
ahsoka tano and lastly luke skywalker
who showed up in the final episode to
take roku with him now throughout the
season we watched as mando attempted to
locate the jedi in order for groku to
begin his training at the time there was
tons of theories flying around that he'd
be hooking up with kanan jairus ezra
bridger or any number of jedi that were
left out in the galaxy there's even some
that said mace windu i'm not joking go
back and watch the tapes now very few
people believe that it was luke and
whenever the fan theory got suggested to
me i quickly shut it down because i
truly thought that one it would cost way
too much to bring mark hamill back and
the age him two that he was done with a
franchise and three that it would have
leaked disney did an outstanding job of
keeping it a secret and as luke's x-wing
slowly rolled into the frame i have to
admit that i couldn't have been happier
to be wrong
at this point in the show the heroes
were at their lowest points and
completely surrounded by mafkidian's
forces it seemed like all hope had been
lost however hope is a theme that is
laced throughout the star wars saga and
seeing luke's x-wing flying to the
hangar made the hairs on the back of my
neck stand up on end i remember it like
it was yesterday and re-watching the
clip brought everything flooding back
now what the creative team did
brilliantly is that they hid luke's face
and still kept us sitting up throughout
the entire scene desperate to see the
reveal even though the black cloak gave
it away showing his arrival through
security cameras was a super smart way
to keep us glued to the scene it allowed
the moment to build up and hearing
motifs from luke's theme laced
throughout helped to create an
anticipation for what would be one of
the biggest star wars moments ever
finally we gotta look up close and
personal and the black cloaked figure
cut through all of the dark troopers
with ease as he moved towards the bridge
you have to remember that the dark
troopers were by far the most fearsome
foes in the mandalorian at this point
and seeing these terminator-esque
enemies getting cut down like they were
battle droids showed how powerful that
luke was now on a meta level luke's
arrival and the way that he travels
through the corridors is purposely shot
to resemble his father's attack in rogue
one one of the best darth vader scenes
of all time had him cutting up the rebel
forces and it's easily the high point of
that movie that feels like the perfect
ending for the film playing those scenes
side by side we see how luke and his dad
share a lot of things in common as
several of their moves mirror one
another it's sort of like poetry they
rhyme and just in the same way that his
father crushed someone using his hand
luke does the same thing with a machine
now just in the same way that the scene
brings us the action it also brings us
the satisfaction of balling like a baby
everyone took the mick out of star wars
theory for crying when luke showed up
but don't lie you did it too didn't you
search your feelings you know it to be
true now luke brought with him not only
a thrilling fight but watching mando
hand over his surrogate son two-packed a
punch that's really hard to forget over
the two seasons the pair had bonded and
though mano didn't want to give him away
he knew that he'd have a better life
with the jedi than he could provide
well as long as he doesn't attend school
at the same time as kylo but their
goodbye is a heartbreaking one and the
mandalorian creed that din jaron was a
part of were instructed not to remove
their helmets under any circumstances
it's something that din wrestled with
throughout both seasons and it was only
when it was absolutely necessary that he
decided to take it off however here he
broke the rules and removed it to say
farewell to grogu face to face for what
may be the final time though he said
he'd see him again we don't know if
that's gonna be true or not and if this
was to be the last ever mandalorian
season it's the perfect way to say
goodbye seeing the little guy reach out
and touch his cheek for the first time
was a heartbreaking moment and his dear
old dad din told him not to be afraid
though the pair didn't want to go they
knew they had to and r2d2 roamed in to
give groggoo someone else to bond with
luke picked up grogu and placed him on
his shoulder as he walked down the
hallway and this too carries a lot of
meaning with it this over the shoulder
shot is something that we've seen echo
throughout both seasons namely when din
was carrying groggu over his and it
perfectly mirrored those moments to show
that he had a new guardian luke's
spotting words were may the force be
with you and not only was this the
character saying it in but it was also
him very much saying it to the audience
who had been desperate to see this side
of luke once more
though the aging was imperfect and there
were a lot of flaws in it as a viewer
it's easy to look past these parts
because of the magic within the scene
that brings back exactly why we all fell
in love with star wars this is a
franchise that's had its ups and downs
over the years but scenes like this
served as a reminder of why it's still
so popular and why people stick with it
throughout their entire lives sure star
wars will have bad movies bad characters
and head scratching twists and turns
sometimes but it's moments like this
that we as a fan base hold out for and
it makes all the disappointments worth
it just to get these glimmers of hope
this was a perfect moment and not only
was it a joyful one but it was also
bittersweet in many regards we know that
mando has just lost the one person that
turned him from a hired gun into an
actual human but beyond that it leads to
an uncertain future as we touched upon
elia luke's jedi academy has somewhat of
a tragic history and just in the same
way that grogu survived order 66 he's
likely going to have to deal with the
rise of kylo ren there's an incredible
mix of emotions that come from this but
even with all that it's difficult not to
get caught up in this moment the music
is perfect the build-up to the scene is
perfect the way that luke mirrors his
father's actions is absolutely
incredible and at the heart of it is an
emotional farewell between a father and
son it really is one of the best moments
that star wars has to offer and it's a
scene that i absolutely love
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you comment
below and let me know if you agree with
us then please hit the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe as we do
videos like this each and every week and
we'd love to have you around in case you
don't know i'm your host paul aka
lukewarm skywalker and we will be
covering star wars visions next week so
i'd love to see you then now we are in a
competition and giving away three copies
of zack snyder's dc trilogy on the 30th
of september and all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the
scene we picked the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of what if episode 6 which
will be linked on screen right now we've
gone over the entire thing from top to
bottom and it's definitely worth
checking out so i'll see you over there
right now you better if not then thank
you for sending through this video i've
been paul you take care of yourself and
i'll see you on the next one peace